Vía thu tưởng thái lan phê tổng tăng Sinoa Traami toàn hình pháp nước này
đình chỉ trực vụ để điều trà gạo buộc ví phạm hình pháp đằng lệ thái lan
và khu khoảng trình trị nghiêm trong.
Lâm dế lên lòng ai về tương lai bất ổn của đất nước
và giặt tăng áp lực lên đến kinh tế vô đáng trước lai.
Cú thể bất ổn trình trị bùng pháp đúng thời điểm thái lan đang đối diện hàng loạt thách tức kinh tế.
Nếu thằng thế giới đã hạn dự bảo tăng trường của thái lan, năm 2020,
hình thân trăm hình thân trăm, xong trị còn một phải tán phân trăm.
khi bà trụ của trình của những kinh tế là dù lịch tư dùng trồng nước và xất khẩu.
Điều gặp khó, ngàn dù lịch vô đồng cóp lượng,
cho gần sách bị anh hưởng nặng nặng nè bởi lần án nình,
sau các bụng bảo lực, căng thà bian rời về căng buồn chia và bất ổn của vực.
Lựa khách trung của bọn 1 tuy trình cũng giả mạnh vì lòng ngày ở đây án toàn.
Trong khi đó, kêu dùng trồng nước bị kiểm hãm bởi nở hộ ra đình đã lên tới tảm,
mấy bây hệ mốn thân trăm của đe pê, mất cảm nhất đồng năm á.
Còn trương trình phát tiền, kích cầu của chính phủ bị hoát nhiều lần khiến người dần mất nhìn tên.
Về sất khẩu, thấy lăng của Wigger hình chiều mất thử lên tới 3 mi só phân trăm,
khi các cuộc đàn phán thương lại sông phương với mi hát hạn gọi người chỉ thống bây,
dừng trở đạm đường thật.
Nè gió án dòng hạn xuất khẩu, sẵn tị trường lợn này.
Lếu khong hạn chính trị không được giải quyết sống,
truyv của thái lăng khó có thể bản hạn những chính xác trên lược dài hạn để vực giải kinh tế.
Nông thời làm phí giảm, nềm tiền của các nhà nổ từ của tế,
trong bối cảnh hẹn này, xưa được chính trị được gọi lệ yếu tổ thèn chốt.
Lể thái lăng tránh rơi sâu của khong hạn kinh tế,
nhưng các chuyên gia cho rằng chưa có giấu khiệu gió gió dọn dàng về giải pháp trò bế tác chính trị.
Nhất là khi tỏa anh hình pháp, chưa anh định thời điểm gia phản quyết,
về số phận của bà phay tông tăng xin ở trái.